[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau et dernier
numéro de paf avant l'été dans lequel
nous allons parler du nouveau patron des
patrons c'est comme ça qu'on dit c'est
peut-être à la formule qui préfèrent
geoffroy roux de bézieux on va parler de
simone devait l'on va parler des maires
qui sont peut-être pas dans une
situation aussi favorable qu'on le
pensait jusqu'à présent
et pour en parler bertrand de créer
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le président
du medef des yvelines
vous êtes un des soutiens vous étiez un
des soutiens de geoffroy roux de bézieux
je viens d'être élu président du medef
on va on va en parler avec vous mustapha
la ba oui bonjour vous êtes de travaux
être pharmacien et vous êtes président
d'honneur d'ubs football club
d'autres c'est tony et président de
pharming citoyens et ben voilà j'avais
pas donner de nom qu'un bureau n'y
aurait tellement de choses à dire mais
oui mais pas assez longs pour soutenir
donc on va s'arrêter là c'était pas dans
son jour je fêterai sert à l'université
de versailles saint quentin ancien doyen
de la faculté de droit
seulement tellement répété et florence
père qui avait choqué avocate au barreau
de versailles chantiers et vous
appartenez aussi au medef absolument on
peut lire on peut le dire on peut le
dire il fait partie du conseil
d'administration et du bureau des médias
78 alors on va commencer par commencer
par cette actualité c'est à dire
l'élection de geoffroy roux de bézieux
direction assez facile plus facile que
peut-être on le pensait puisqu'il est
élu avec presque presque 60 % des voix
donc c'est un nouveau alors du patron
des patrons lui c'est une formule qu'il
ne revendique pas
il est le porte parole de maintenant il
n'est pas le patron des patrons il porte
parole de patrons alors vous êtes vous
prononcer pour lui comme le medef des
yvelines pour pour quelles raisons tout
est bon les deux candidats sur dix
colonnes alexandre saubot alexandre
saubot geoffroy des yeux tous les deux
sont de brillants sujets c'est
indéniable dit les deux vice-présidents
du medef la charge du pôle social
l'ordre du pôle économique
bon il n'y a pas de débat sur la qualité
des hommes il ya sur ma je crois et
parce que c'est une conversation de
confection qui est qu'il faut le medef
doit être plus proche de son père a plus
proche de ses territoires et geoffroy et
son équipe pour moi incarne mieux ses
valeurs de territoire de terrain
notamment le ralliement qui était très
important dans notre prise décision
parce que vous et je le soutiens mais
mais les yvelines le soutien non
puisqu'il va votre prose ministration
l'assemblée générale nous soutenons roux
de bézieux et le le fait que le rallye
mort de l'un des smart afld avait lâché
et pierre orageux qui a incarné c'est
votre cas et 3 soit totalement rallia
roux de bézieux a été déterminant notre
votre choix
alors on peut faire peut-être que aussi
un petit bilan
du monde de pierre gattaz quand même
qu'ils étaient quand même alors il a
quand même beaucoup obtenu pour les
entreprises il y avait on se souvient
tous du pin c'est un million d'emplois
on a eu l'impression parfois qu'il avait
obtenu plus qu'il avait données je veux
un peu remettre les choses à l'endroit
on n'obtient pas pour l'entreprise on
obtient pour la société quand ils se
serraient vont bien quand les a
décoincés font bien c'est une image que
je pourrai cas c'est qu'on parle de
cadeaux faits aux patrons ouais faut
arrêter ya jamais de cadeau fait aux
patrons quand quand on quand on perd
mais quand on fait baisser les bras mais
non mais un avantage c'est un bref
social quand dansant quand on baisse les
charges
moi je sais de quoi je parle tant
qu'entrepreneur la france dont on
imagine que les entreprises sondées tout
d'aider du cac40 milliardaire et
actionnaire terry qui s'adressent les
coûts d'exploitation à la réalité c'est
comme la phrase de paye de pme avec des
entreprises dont là que je crois que 96%
de mémoire insee doivent faire moins 10
salariés
bon ces jeunes d'entre vous la cession
des tpe et des pme 80 15% triste du
medef font moins de 10 salariés
donc les patrons d'entreprises
mais quand on leur baisse leurs charges
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont besoin de croître
qu'est ce qu'ils font mais ils bougent
ils embauchent donc les cadeaux fut aux
patrons se prendre un cadeau pour la
société y'a pas de cadeaux aux patrons
et des cadeaux faits mais je vais un peu
dans votre sang sur ce qu'elle compte
c'est vrai qu'on s'était beaucoup moqué
de ce pays de cinq millions mais on n'y
a pas cette scène 285 1913 sens apparent
et l'emploi on est alors justement les
paroisses des pierres on est tout près
on est tout près toulouse s'est moqué de
monsieur ce plateau j'ai eu des docteurs
qui était de 2-2 syndicats employés de
ce gâteau famille andrade années il a
réussi on a fait 850 sur mandat 850
mètres on est dans la création par an si
on continue dans ce train là on le fera
le lion emploi et pierre riou les autres
jouent déjà les îles et j'aurais dû dire
2 billions parce que ça avait il dit
bertrand laquait
sens ça se décide on nous dit toujours
la croissance n'est pas là la croissance
ne vient pas la croissance asie la
croissance et palente ne rien faire sauf
que pour faire baisser le chômage c'est
le sun qui est important on parle de 750
mille huit cent mille emplois créés il
ya également la destruction
donc ce qui est important c'est le sol
parce que pour passer de 3 4 millions de
de chemin beaucoup moins en tous les cas
en espérant au plein emploi ce qui est
important c'est donc le différentiel
entre ce que l'on craignait ce qu'était
voilà le différentiel est donc 200 euros
quand c'est vrai que c'est pas c'est pas
un débat pratiquement le chômage à une
époque on en parlait tous les mois on
faisait un bilan tous les mois et c'est
le seul qui est important on peut
décréter un million d'emplois
si on en détruit autant fait des bêtises
de toute façon ça va mettre le doigt là
dessus la destruction d'emplois
il y en aura marre et devaient y en aura
oui un hors la société bas récemment
révolution il va falloir se changer les
choses et des créations il y en aura
encore écouté hier j'ai des discussions
constructives
j'ai déjà les halles à la mutualité et
se fait pas du périph
je vais les appeler le met a qui
travaillent avec des robes aux tons
d'heure ben ça fera autant demain en
autant de mecs en moins avec un mac il
articule trahi ses robots on va aux
vagues caissière mais c'est vrai que là
aussi une évolution
alors après vous savez bien mais il y
aura 13 ans quand jean ferrat non mais
j'achète votre question parce que
justement le fait de mettre des caisses
automatiques permet une meilleure
productivité
par contre qu'est ce qui fait que les
gens viennent chez nous et reviennent
chez nous c'est pas la caisse
automatique
c'est peut-être le seul où il acceptait
que sourire lagacé allemand et donc tout
ce qu'on aura détruire peut-être en
caisse on va le mettre en aie aie aie en
service parce qu'on va muter évolué
alors c'est vrai que le côté mécanique
de l'acteur répétitif peut-être fait
part à la machine par contre le sourire
l'être humain qui accueillera
à chartres on a besoin de lui pour
choyer le client c'est pour ça qu'ils
aideront chez nous aussi donc on créera
des emplois il y à il ya une
réconciliation c'est pour tenter qu'ils
étaient n'était pas aussi avant entre
les français les entreprises ça on le
sent bien il ya quand même une image un
peu près ce que regardent parfois du
dessin week-end du medef non depuis que
le medef
enfin depuis que le cnpf est devenu
medef
il ya eu un progrès enfin déjà dans ce
set confédération nationale du patronat
avec face des messieurs en costume trois
pièces et ses
enfin l'image est aussi importante et
puis le discours a changé lui aussi
c'est vrai que enfin je vous rejoins
c'est largement dire que on sait à peu
près aujourd'hui que là que les
activités économiques développées par
par les entreprises basse elle le sait
l'une des sources de richesse absolument
faux a lancé pas la seule mais c'est une
des choses de richesse monétaire en tout
cas fondamentales notamment entre autres
du medef qui a permis aux politiques de
comprendre enfin ce que c'était qu'une
entreprise sur dix ans déjà
oui mais ça fait quoi mais ça fait quand
même 15 20 ans le discours politique
change vis-à-vis des entreprises mais ça
c'est un témoin de l'idéologie dans le
suffolk probablement qu'elle a eu
pendant longtemps dogmatisme et sa date
de mitterrand la réconciliation c'est
dans le oui dans le ciel c'est le
tournant ce sentiment qu'on a fait un
casting qu'autre chose parce que je
trouve que notre ami je froid a d'abord
choisi de ne pas et que patron des
patrons ce qui était quand même à peu
près d'étiquettes qu'on donnait au
peuple octobre ou président on aimait
bien d'ailleurs s'appeler le patron des
patrons parce que le patron ce qu'on
leur vend dit que au medef et dans
l'entreprise en général
là c'est plutôt porte parole moi je le
connais plus comme porte parole se jouer
dans toutes les émissions
on voyait souvent sur bfm oui c'est une
vedette cédait 2
que on a le sentiment qu mais le
sentiment simplement puisque je suis pas
un spécialiste du medef unis membres du
ménage mais de l'extérieur ça donne
vraiment le sentiment de quelqu'un des
médias quelqu'un de la com et qui vient
sur ce terrain là tout de suite c'est à
dire je suis pas le patron des patrons
je suis porte parole et on va faire de
la pédagogie on va expliquer que ce ne
sont pas des cadeaux aux patrons mais
que ça va dans le sens de l'entreprise
en gros c'est plus l'offre que la
demande ou la demande que l'offre donc
sur ce conflit là on a un porte parole
on a quelqu'un qui va être pédagogue qui
va être un homme de communication
enfin c'est le sentiment que j'en ai à
tout ça au delà de ces compétences parce
que j'ai des cousins officialisé
compétences gravier sur le fait que j'ai
bien voter dans une période de guerre et
des emplois qui vont des emplois
nouveaux qui vont apparaître enfin de
nouveaux secteurs qui vont apparaître
d'autres qui vont disparaître
c'est aussi quelqu'un qui est qui a fait
beaucoup d'entreprises dans le no
tamment dans la téléphonie
donc quelqu'un qui est très branché avec
les startups la nouvelle économie
complètement complètement non mais ça
c'est son côté va résolument tourné vers
l'avenir
alors à toi t'as qu'avec ça ne le soit
pas mais non il incarne encore une fois
bien que les deux candidats étaient de
valeur d'ailleurs pour montrer at elle
prédit fédérateur l'un des premiers
gestes de geoffroy a été d'accueillir un
invité permanent alexandre donc aux
exécutifs en disant tu seras ceci à tous
ce sera avec nous il a fait un discours
très rassembleur la décharge d'alexandre
aussi savez nous a fait le l'aveu d'un
secret entre nous mais ils s'étaient
promis à mi avion amis pendant amis
après c'est donc rooney non on a eu une
très belle compétition
je pense que les deux compétiteurs sont
toujours restés
un niveau de débat assez haut moi je
voulais faire remarquer ça c'est que
quand je vois pas beaucoup de débats
dans beaucoup d'organes et son syndicale
quand il faut changer la tête
je ne sais pas combien d'organisation et
j'en connais tu pourrais me le dire que
70 mais moi je vois pas comment ça se
passe à france 2 on a eu un vrai débat
on a eu des gens et non ya pas eu de de
boules puantes de dos et ça c'est pas
dans ces premières élections de
président du medef six mois commencé en
tant que grand temps que votre wiimote
en sauna 2e en kata et et ça c'est
dépassé de manière aussi simple regard
du pire c'était d'aller vers un
ralliement total voilà qu'hier c'était
c'était 4% qu'il était seul candidat
justement geoffroy s'était rallié à
pierre gattaz oubliez pas de un moment
alors si on prend un peu avant où il y
avait des grands patrons qui disait ça
sera un tel et tout le monde avaliser un
peu la halle à la décision de ces grands
patrons là c'était c'était comme ça que
celles qui leur paraissaient pas une
parisien de laurence parisot
bon évidemment beaucoup de qualités mais
enfin je veux dire il ya des gens qui
ont dit voilà il faut une femme ça sera
elle
c'était vraiment un âge et je pense
qu'avant de l'exemple mais a su faire
une vraie campagne c'est une vraie
campagne et avec une véritable élection
l'élection il est choisir habituellement
choisis par les fédérations et les
territoires puisque je fais des
racailles toi est-ce que alors là c'est
vrai qu'il ya un gouvernement un
président de la république qui est
plutôt favorable aux séances entre fès
qui soutient quand ils étaient
intervenus dans la région du medef du
temps de pierre gattaz
il ya eu un engouement quand il était
encore ministre
de l'économie pour emmanuel macron c'est
vrai que là vous avez un président qui
est à l' écoute on peut pas dire
françois l'on ne naît pas été
l'entreprise
j'aime il ya quand même mais là c'est
vrai qu'il ya
il n'est pas une sorte de convivialité
politiques ou économiques entre le entre
le pouvoir les le madoff
je pense que ma kron a compris d'abord
il la lance dans sa campagne
présidentielle et il a compris
qu'aujourd'hui si on veut être
développées d'emploi développer les
richesses il fallait devait l'entreprise
d'ailleurs c'est cette exigence qui doit
se passait d'ailleurs c'est pas hasard
c'est qu'on a on a des points de vente
qui remonte on a on arrête chômage qui
va s
ça a profité à tout le monde les
soi-disant cadeaux aux patrons vont
profiter à toute la société
j'aimais pas le bon cadeau un essai
placard parce que c'est jamais un cadeau
j'ai fait un choix
ouverture vers l'offre c'est hollande
et quand vous dites il a tout compris il
est dans cette continuité et il va même
plus loin mais on est c'est un choix
deux parties d'aller vers l'offre
c'est un choix politique de favoriser
cette
voilà cette option ce ne sont pas des
cadeaux mais dans une négociation un
moment donné c'est on discute pour le
coup là c'est la notion d'offre et de
demande quand c'est des négociations
syndicales c'est une manière de dire le
patronat aimerait aller dans un sens et
les salariés dans un autre abandonnée il
ya quand même une confrontation d'idées
c'est pas tellement qui les comprime
c'est que c'est un choix qui levait et
c'est un choix qui pour le coup sera
sanctionné par les urnes
quand on fera un bilan parce que il a
tout compris ça va mieux il voit j'aime
bien je suis j'aime bien entendre que
les chiffres soirée exposé devant nous
et ça est faux
cela dit le fameux pour quatre ans le
chômage c'est un marqueur d'élection
politique c'est celui qui fait gagner ou
faire des élections
oui jusqu'à jusqu'à la maladresse de
l'inversion ce cadre la seule
incertitude donc il faut pas trop
s'engage pas trop s'engager uniquement
sur un jeu sur un thème qui a décidé les
relations entre geoffroy roux de bézieux
emmanuel macron ce qu'on dit qu'il ya un
petit contentieux
on connait sa copie et quand quand il y
la commission attali dont faisait partie
jean favreau debaisieux est
emmanuel macron était le secrétaire et à
l'époque geoffroy roux de bézieux était
déjà une vedette emma tronc d'un inconnu
et macro l'avait dit on pourrait déjeuné
ensemble autour du j'ai pas le temps et
je crois qu'il le regrette un peu depuis
on trouve du temps quoi attention sur ce
sujet vous à autre chose non ça va si
tout va bien alors on va continuer
jusqu'à ce qui est intéressant c'est qui
il est bon d'avoir un medef en pleine
forme plutôt qu'un medef
voilà contrarier la même façon que il
est bon d'avoir la parité il ya quand
même un mot à dire sur la situation des
syndicats enfin après tout le medef est
un syndicat alors est ce qu'ils ont dit
souvent des syndicats de salariés mais
regardez ils sont très peu représentatif
la plupart de leurs adhérents se rend
dans la fonction publique il ya encore
pas tous les noms
est-ce que je me lâche et représentative
des patrons alors pas suffisamment il
les met pas suffisamment bien sûr le
medef tout comme stowe mesure syndicale
souffre d'un manque d'adhésion
aujourd'hui deux portions la proportion
de syndiqués parcequ'elle est peut être
un petit peu supérieure dont les
patronales mais mais
on est un peuple un peu plus nombreux
mais et sajoo 1 % price est pas c'est
pas pour réhabiliter de huy 3,4 oui mais
non c'est très faible
c'est tout a lancé le syndicaliste
trois employés c'était le français se
qualifie pas c'est compliqué de faire
adhérer un patron et on est sûr de lui
dans les petites entreprises qui
auraient un qui a un manque de
syndicalisation soleil on a parfois eu
l'impression aussi que le medef était un
peu le porte parole des grandes
entreprises
il est en train de sauver nom et concept
du canard cédé une grande entreprise
s'ils voulaient apprendre à les total au
hasard ce que voudrait que le patron de
total il a besoin d'un bref nous en
république ou bien il a beau ne rêvons
pas trop là pour se défendre il a un drh
ceinture les grosses boîtes donc pas
besoin d'un gazon patronale l'ogs à 80
l'avait fait pour défendre les autres
comment les fêtes pour descendre des
centres non mais est ce que c est ce que
c'est dans ce creuset des petits doux
d'aider de toutes petites entreprises
que vous auriez besoin de recruter
puisque c'est 40 40
un pari félicien pour terminer à revoir
les autres qui je crois qu'il y en a 800
en france à val d'or intermédiaire c'est
à peu près le sbf120 de son mouvement
allez on va on a limité tout ça il ya
trois millions d'entreprises en france
je conçois que ça avec lenny personnel
oui le territoire le chant est beaucoup
plus large des samoa 10 années notre
côté donc d'abord il est c'est un homme
qui a aussi un problème de
représentativité
lui ce qui est dommage c'est juste pour
compléter ce que dit bertrand c'est que
l'on voit des entreprises qui viennent
taper à la porte du medef parce qu'ils
ont un problème parce qu'ils ont un
problème avec lui parce qu'ils ont un
problème avec l'urssaf
parce qu'ils ont un problème de
prud'hommes parce qu'ils ont un problème
au tribunal de commerce et c'est à ce
moment là qu'ils se disent ah bah j'ai
besoin de quelqu'un va tient peut-être
que je peux mais c'est au moment où on
s'est peut-être trop tard d'ailleurs
donc à mon avis si ça vient du fait
d'une très mauvaise compréhension nos
astuces sur comment nous fonctionnons je
suis d'entreprise c'est un patron de pme
en france le logo tout type même de
petites pme
il a mené un guidon il va pas forcément
temps de regarder autour de lui et égaux
segment explique comment ça fonctionne
il use des grands yeux il mais ça
fonctionne comme ça mais c'est n'aime
pas quand un monde violent parce qu'il
est polarisée par le développement son
entreprise ces voitures les prem's
addario les charges à payer enfin bon
c'est la vie de l'entrepreneur est par
essence un indépendant milito est par
essence dépendant donc c'est pas on n'a
pas lésiné j'avais à quatre petites
parties visiter une une ville en
allemagne une grande sûrs d'eux alors je
ne sais plus laquelle ces colonies
j'avais grande ville et le syndicat
local
fédérer plus d'entreprises que toutes
les deux france genou le medef deuxième
local une ehsayer d'évasion c'est vrai
c'est une grande ville allemande c'est
pas paris
parce qu'il y aurait des réformes
institutionnelles ou ses cultures oui on
peut réformer la réforme les
institutions rendre l'adhésion
obligatoire à mai la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme s'y
oppose pour obtenir des ventes a été
rejetée
oui oui on peut pas obliger les gens à
adhérer à une association indique un
parti après la passe
ce serait quoi tu es notre droit
intitulé un patron en étant impliqué
obligatoires michel martinez le sis dans
la représentation c'est que quand vous
adhérez à un mouvement patronal
si vous militez après il faut avoir des
mandats un bon lancer du temps un mandat
salariés on lui dégage du temps il est
rémunéré et il peut se faire qu un
patron de pe quand il va se retrouver
tout seul il faut jaf l'entreprise et
que j'aille me fait me taper mes mandats
je peux vous assurer jeter des ponts
savoir c'est travailler voilà savoir
quand des mandats qui vous prennent deux
à trois jours par semaine
oui très lourd mais que vous financez
vous même que vous voulez vous
débrouiller pour financer vos vaut ça
aussi pour moi c'est un des réels frein
pour les patrons encore une fois une
grosse boîte qui délègue un cadre aux
prud'hommes sa peau ce faire ils font
ils ont les moyens mais un patron de pme
qu'à cinq salariés et qui va partir deux
jours par semaine pour la cause commune
ouais ça sert et des salariés n'ont pas
ce problème là qu'ils ont ils ont en
outre appelé c'est que c'était pourtant
c'est m
j'ai entendu florence qui disait ça
l'autre ça l'a vraiment je m'insulter et
était de référence à l'inversé de paris
et xénophobe il ya c'est pas un problème
les ja mais il ya actuellement le
mondial de football
et alors les entreprises sont
confrontées à ça il ya des badges à 16
heures qu'est ce qu'on ferait à 16h
alors il ya par exemple la sodexo
dans le territoire qui trouvait l'idée
on va tout le monde s'arrête pendant les
matchs de foot on regarde un petit sujet
là dessus assister à la victoire de
l'équipe de france face au pérou alors
que l'on est censé se trouver derrière
son bureau une réalité chez le groupe
sodexo basé à guyancourt l'opérateur de
restauration et de services accueille
900 salariés
son mondial 2018 est un moyen de
rassembler encore plus son personnel
l'organisation en tout cas de des matchs
en tout cas de la diffusion des matchs
pour la coupe du monde ça rentre
pleinement dans le cadre de parole à ce
qu'on a envie d'offrir à nos
collaborateurs sur site pour pour leur
qualité de vie en plus de la
retransmission des matches des bleus sur
écran géant la salle de restauration a
été décorée aux couleurs du drapeau
tricolore
une urne a été mise à disposition pour
que chacun puisse parier avant le
lancement du match un moment que
n'aurait pas manqué martin laetitia et
sylvie ce super puis ça permet de se
retrouver sur un moment convivial donc
c'est vrai ça génial ça nous permet un
autre cadre agréable et puis c'est la
fin du monde nous pensons qu'à la france
sur 200 enfants c'est puisqu'il faut une
plage de travail assez flexible donc
vrai que vu leur c'était quand même
facile à s'organiser selon une étude
menée par le site internet bureaux
locaux en france 36 % des entreprises
ont décidé de diffuser certains matchs
dans les espaces communs 19 % des
entreprises autorisent leurs salariés
regarder les matchs discrètement
al'inverse un quart des entreprises ont
décidé d'interdire à leurs salariés de
regarder les matchs au bureau de toute
façon tout le monde a envie de regarder
le match ça arrive une fois tous les
quatre ans et c'est plutôt un événement
qui est très fédérateur qui est
conviviale donc enfin voilà on s'est dit
autant l'organiser de manière officielle
pour fourre tout le monde et pour que
les gens voient là puissent le voir en
toute tranquillité les salariés de
sodexo vont encore avoir de nouvelles
occasions de partager ces moments de
convivialité puisque les hommes de
didier deschamps sont qualifiés pour les
huitièmes de finale
c'est vrai que c'est alors et c'est à la
fois un moyen de se solidariser les
salariés quand il ya des événements
comme ça et ça pose évidemment des
problèmes de présence au travail parce
que je pense que beaucoup de gens qui à
16 heures c'est vrai qu'on est des
horaires là qui sont compliqués va la
france d'où la plupart du temps à 16
heures donc les gens ont envie de voir
ça comment vous faites vous pour les
moins de monde il ya moins de monde dans
les pharmacies on accueille le public
donc on s'interrompt pas un match de
foot
cela étant toutes ont des alertes
maintenant donc un moment donné il ya
l'alertent du but quand même
et souvent c'est un partage qui peuvent
avoir avec tel aviv
non seulement pas hypocrite non plus
dire que c'est un moment de communion
jeux d'antan dans le reportage c'est un
moment de communion et c'est bien de se
retrouver
on va pas s'en priver mais il ya des
coupes du monde de tous les sports donc
moi je suis un adepte du foot j'aime le
foot donc volontiers pour la coupe du
monde de football mais ça peut créer des
précédents c'est la jurisprudence coupe
du monde on pourrait le faire pour
d'autres sports pour d'autres événements
et l'entreprise commune
en même temps qu'ils soient autant
assemblage non mais pour ceux qui
n'aiment pas le foot il ya probablement
une sonate ou la pétanque pour les pour
les marseillais
adeptes de la pétanque mais c'est vrai
que curieusement je trouve quand même
que on retrouve volontiers du temps pour
la coupe du monde de football mais
certains pourraient dire mais moi je
suis intéressé par d'autres sports et
surtout quand c'est l'équipe de france
sauf que c'est les patrons et qui sait
de cette tentation de dire voilà on
s'arrête parce qu'ils ont envie devant
watch mais ça veut dire que globalement
le patron et footeux et qui peut laisser
son équipe
moi ça me plaît je n'ai simplement pas
parce qu'il faut pardonner mais j'ai une
forte de mordre mais mes salariés alors
et un truc qui tombe bien c'est qu'en
fait quand c'est la france ne valent que
regarder les clients sont pas là non
plus voilà ils sont pas là non plus le
maillot des déserts donc les gens qui se
disent ne jamais y aller parce que là il
faudrait pas là on a un grand écran dans
la salle de réunion et est en fait ils
sont quasiment tous devant le foot il n
ya un minimum en bas mais mais mais
c'est pas très grave parce que
malheureusement en match de coupe du
monde
les clients désertent audrey les matchs
devraient pas leur consigne afin de
jouer pas fermé fermé alors on peut pas
fermer pour autant que je veux tout
d'abord d'être ouvert au douar se doit
d'être ouvert au vent des télévisions
alors format qu'il vend pas de tuner mai
mais parce que sinon c'est vrai que
j'observais même cabinet d'avocats donc
nous on a fermé le cabinet de 16h à
17h30 on a basculé le téléphone à
l'extérieur il n'y a pas eu un appel au
pub à côté du cabinet et il n'y a pas eu
un appel de clients et les noms d'autres
16h et 17h30 il pas eu un appel ça
repris après et j'ai pas reçu un mail
non plus alors que je reçois les walkman
enfin un truc c'était incroyable et
c'est la france continue sa wii party
c'est 20 heures mardi ses pairs et après
ça va être un peu pareil chez les
pompiers au samu c'est pareil ça va loin
regardez votre nom oui quand je peux
bien sûr parce que bon globalement je
regarde ceux de 20h à ouïr tout vous
dire je reste solidaire avec les équipes
donc c'est ouvert je suis avec eux
et nous les clients monde année ils
rentrent avec des ordonnances ya pas que
des sportifs il ya aussi des gens âgés
chronique et qui ont besoin leur merkel
mais je regarderai quand je peux bien
sûr
alors on dirait que le football c'est un
moment de rassemblement
il y en a eu un autre qui a eu lieu
dimanche c'était simone veil qui est
entré au avec antoine vallières au
panthéon
alors c'est intéressant parce que l et
es l et es pro européenne elle était
pour l'ouverture elle était ni de droite
ni de gauche ni de droite
c'est rien fait on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui c'est tout ce que rejette
un peu une grande partie de l'opinion
avec la montée des populismes non voilà
la c3 vous avez 3 représente la
résistance la réconciliation oui
l'ouverture sur l'europe la défense des
droits des femmes elle représente
tellement tellement tellement tellement
de choses que mais c'est vrai je disais
un article sur des jeunes femmes qui ont
sorti justement pour dimanche des
t-shirts avec une photo un peu moderne
simone veil et qui avaient collé des
affiches et qui se sont retrouvés des
affiches aujourd'hui comme vous le dites
taguée avec des insignes à 16 avec
meurtrière marqué sur les affiches
encore là là dimanche je compte donc je
répondrais oui patrice c'est à dire que
effectivement elle revendique 1 mais
c'est vrai qu'elle revendique des
combats le rebond dès l'ouverture dont
vous parlez elle revendique thoniers
droite depuis très longtemps elle est
donc à la modernité par excellence le
féminisme et en même temps c'est ce que
rejette effectivement de plus en plus
les français voient le monde mais gris
le voir le monde je vais plus loin
cela étant je voudrais une explication
c'est que peut-être que l'enfance de
simone veil est marqué par son enfance
marquée par son histoire proche en tout
cas des événements tragiques à la plus
connaître donc la guerre beaucoup de
personnages issus de cette de cette
période prône l'ouverture prône la
réconciliation et les rondes parce qu'à
un moment donné ils ont connu le vrai
ils ont connu la guerre ils ont connu et
j'ai l'impression qu'on s'en éloigne
tellement qu'aujourd'hui que c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on peut imaginer
alors qu'elle peut pour par définition
revenir donc elle a raison elle continue
à avoir raison et si on est de moins en
moins nombreux à la suivre eh bien on a
tort voilà c'est juste que ça sur le sur
le fronton du panthéon des grands hommes
la patrie reconnaissante à partie et
patrice nom des femmes oui j'allais dire
est ce qu'on doit changer
ah oui aux grandes familles
c'est vrai que on est dans une société
où les démocraties ce méfie un peu des
héros des gens qui dépasse enfin
et qu'est ce que c'est la figure d'un
grand homme ou d'une grande femme
aujourd'hui dire qu'il n'ya plus de
chefs de guerre il ya plus de gens qui
sont prêts à donner leur vie pour mon
pour la patrie est plus grande au monde
qu'il peut le faire peut-être beltrame
jorgo riis a pas longtemps c'est quand
même assez exceptionnel qu'est ce que
c'est un grand homme dans une démocratie
ll cristallisait et elle et ceux qui
sont au panthéon plus ou moins elle
cristallisée sur elle sur sur donc sur
une personne enfin un homme au sens
fondamental terme mais venir qui vient
de la terre des valeurs des combats une
histoire c'est la rencontre entre entre
le singulier sa propre personne et puis
l'universel mais enfin l'universel tel
qu'on le conçoit tels que notre histoire
notre tradition notre culture le conçois
et il ya aussi toujours une part de
comment dirais-je et c'est pas lui faire
insulte à sa mémoire mais une part de
fabrication d'un héros de fabrication
d'un grand homme mais qu'elle ne devrait
même pas se poser
enfin je dis surtout pas parce que j'ai
lu des entretiens qui lui ont vu ou
entendu je ne sais plus où il avait posé
la question d'ailleurs imaginez vous un
jour être inhumé aux côtés où elle avait
levé les yeux au ciel en disant faire
une idée très facilement et je sais je
me répète puisque nous en avions parlé à
l'époque de ses obsèques il ya un mois
je enfin je me souviens lorsqu'elle
était lorsque simone veil étaient
très engagé dans la vie politique alors
on dit elle était ni droite ni de gauche
etc
elle avait la peau ou plutôt était dans
des gouvernements dans des gouvernements
de droite mais d'une droite tout à fait
république allait elle a été avec elle
et avec giscard et balladur
voilà la falaise elle a d'ailleurs très
souvent ce qui me plaît beaucoup étaient
dissidente
oui c'est une femme libre mais nous
n'étions qu'à gauche oui voilà vous
pouvez pas tellement la solitude
politiquement même si elle a plutôt
collaborer à droite plutôt conservateur
actuellement mais à l'époque
lorsqu'elles étaient engagés dans ce
dans cette vie politique en la personne
ne la considérait comme une forme
d'héroïne ou de grains en deux alors
elle a toujours été une figure un peu à
part mais elle n'a jamais été la seule
est en tout cas elle n'a pas été
considérée au point de l'avoir comme
étant les dons qu'il ya eu depuis une
une fabrique est né ce que vous dites
est vrai parce que m'ont dit ça a été la
première présidente du parlement
européen ce qui est vrai est lui en tout
cas oui
ce qui est vrai mais comment ça se passe
c'est schmitt et giscard la m à l'époque
enfin je crois pas me tromper en disant
que tout le monde se fiche éperdument du
parlement européen mais enfin c'est
symbolique mais la première élection des
députés européens c'est 1977
mais c'est bon c'est symbolique ont en
effet le chemisier et giscard en ont
fait un symbole si un symbole absolument
mais justement je reviens à cette figure
des grands hommes est ce que c'est pas
au fond des gens qui font honneur à nos
valeurs même si ces valeurs sont parfois
battu en brèche vous contestez pas par
justement les populismes pas au fossat
fait honneur à l'idée qu'on pourrait se
faire de la france quoi fin des temps
c'est surtout la référence à l'état
général c'est à dire l'idée selon
laquelle on considère que comment dire
le droit enfin j'allais dire le droit
mais c'est surtout l'idée qu'on se fait
de son pays
malgré tout ce qui peut être dit ou tout
ce qui peut être débattue on a le
sentiment que pour le en tous les cas
pour son propre pays on a une idée qu'on
veut la défendre malgré ce qu'on peut
entendre et c'est l'histoire qui vous
donne raison ou pas mais c'est pas les
peuples pendant qu'on discours qui vous
disent de faire ou de ne pas faire donc
ça m'en donner c'est de rejoindre j'y
vais j'y vais et l'histoire me donnera
raison parce que j'en suis convaincu il
ya des tas d'exemples pour ça que ce
soit pendant la guerre ou même depuis
pour la peine de mort ou pour d'autres
pour d'autres idées combattu c'est de se
dire la raison d'état d'abord l'intérêt
général
d'abord et moi je suis j'ai le sentiment
que c'est bon pour mon film et agiraient
politiciens après on a l'impression que
c'est pas tout à fait le cas et je l'en
jetterai pas la pierre c'est quand même
très compliqué c'est facile de le dire
de notre de notre place aujourd'hui mais
c'est vrai qu'on a la tentation de céder
à ceux à tout ce qui se dit tout ce
qu'on voudrait tout de suite sans penser
à l'intérêt général des corporatismes le
communautarisme enfin toutes ces notions
qui laisse un moment donné que les
individus sont importants oui mais
l'intérêt général aussi probablement que
c'est sur ce terrain là que les hommes
politiques ou les hommes politiques se
placent l'intérêt général d'abord le 20°
qui parlait dé et y avait effectivement
ça prend une figure philippe pépin
si vous analysez en 1118 42e même
beaucoup de 947
vous n'êtes pas tout à fait le même
bonhomme quoi il va pas être payés au
même endroit au bon moment
et pourtant c'est le même homme c'est un
maréchal de france qui a fait ce qu'il a
fait mais la vision que nous portons que
le peuple français partent sur lui elle
n'est pas vraiment la même à l'achat
avec le recueil de toute l'histoire
voilà une histoire qui note
voilà étant donné un moment donné qui va
donner vous parlez de posture sur dix
sur la voie alors c'est une affaire
compliquée la sphère d'aider des
réfugiés et des migrants mais n'a pas
l'impression que les hommes politiques
des gouvernements les pouvoirs se
détermine par posture il ya ceux qui
accueillent à ceux qui attention pas de
ça chez nous dit joe qui montrent leurs
muscles
est-ce qu'on n'est pas plus dans la
posture au fond que dans la résolution
de la question qui est quand même
question très très forte celle en
silence parce que on est face à quelque
chose de complexe alors complexe c'est
pas forcément synonyme de compliqué mais
là en l'occurrence je crois que c'est
les deux à la fois complexe et compliqué
et puis en face on a le discours
politique qui par nature est un discours
simpliste un discours de simplification
donc la vérité elle est ni dans ceux qui
disent pas de ça chez nous et hélas il
ya 60% plus des français surtout ne
veulent pas pas de ces gens là chez nous
et elle n'est pas non plus du côté
ouvrons les portes soyez les bienvenus
et c'est donc le le là aussi peut-être
l'objet de pas l'homme où la femme
d'état mais le l'élu un peu sérieux un
peu crédible se reconnaît lorsqu'il de
mon point de vue lorsqu'il prend en
compte cette complexité et ils essayent
de l'expliquer de dire aux gens c'est
pas simple du tout alors il faut faut
pas fermer complètement les portes mais
il faut sans doute non plus ne pas les
ouvrir totalement
mais ce discours il est au fond
inaudible dans l'arène politique parce
que parce que chacun voit un peu
l'intérêt politique de se faire ceci à
dire ceux ci et ça peut marcher en
italie notamment
forcément ça voyez vous il ya déjà
longtemps
de ce que disait michel rocard roulant
mais je compte sa part la paraphrase
absolument il était dans cette
complexité très souvent d'ailleurs et il
ne renonçait pas essayé de l'expliquer
c'est compliqué à entendre quand même
pas alors c'est compliqué pour les ceux
qui nous gouvernent pour ceux qui sont à
la manoeuvre s'est compliquée pour la
complexité bien mais c'est compliqué
aussi pour les auditeurs pour nous un
moment donné c'est ya pas une thune un
moment donné on a du mal à gérer les
problèmes de scolarisation et eric
comment on va faire avec d'autres et un
moment donné on a l'impression qu'il ya
un envahissement total que par
définition on va avoir le grand
remplacement on n'a pas suffisamment
d'argent pour ceux qui sont là on en
aura encore moins pour d'autres qu'ils
aillent donc c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué moi je suis dans la suite dans
l'action associative
on a travaillé par exemple sur les plans
banlieues on voit bien comment les dans
les plans banlieues il ya des choses à
essayer de résoudre à un moment donné
c'est l'idée c'est ouais mon nous en
rajoute tout le temps faire qu on a déjà
du mal à traiter les problèmes en france
et on nous rajoute ces listes parce qu'à
un moment donné il s'agit pas simplement
leur donner à bouffer parce que c'était
ça on dirait que tu es font leur donne à
manger tournant serez d'accord il faut
les accueillir
et tout le monde serait d'accord
simplement tout le monde se dit mais pas
simplement il faut aussi qu'ils aient un
job messieurs du du medef
il faut également qu'ils aient un
logement est donc un moment donné il ya
toute une perspective qui va se mettre
en avant et c'est toujours pareil c'est
comment on fait et avec 2 milliards de
dette ça c'est une équation un peu
compliqué donc les françaises sont
plutôt généreux en tous les cas moi j'ai
le sentiment
ils sont très ouverts à cette question
migratoire c'est par les émigrés qui lui
est réservé car c'est pas les émigrés
qui dirait le contraire mais bien un
moment donné tout le monde se pose la
même question
on y arrive déjà pas qu'est ce qu'on
doit faire
est-ce que c'est l'heure de vérifier
simplement est ce que l'économie a
besoin d'eux
de nouveaux travailleurs de migrants par
exemple clairement tels que c'est comme
ça non non non lui il ya eu des millions
d'euros on a eu des périodes entre les
sauvages brutal qu'il sans assimilation
est alors si vous voulez on est certain
nombre le club nombreux à penser au
medef non un immigrant attention à ce
que je vais dire non pas forcément le pr
ne s'est pas d'accueillir des immigrés
de ne pas les accueillir
c'est peut-être une autre solution c'est
qu'ils restent chez eux et pour ça s'est
développé et l'investir investir qui
créent l'emploi des salles l'ordonnait
l'emploi en france est une connerie leur
donner un emploi dans leur pays
d'origine mais c'est laisser la solution
mais depuis le temps la coopération et
leur sauf que ça reste des moyens à
donner quand même c'est un moment donné
des finances et deuxièmement souris
messi est intelligent et sait sauf que
c'est souvent capté à m
ce qui avait capté en sommes encore les
invités international productif par les
élites se souvent capté à huy le vrai
problème est la cause du problème quand
on s'attaque à quelque chose mieux vaut
s'attaquer à la crosse quels effets
boule vidal et en l'occurrence la cause
elle est dans l'eau la plupart du temps
donc c'est plutôt un freeze parce que
nous ne pouvons pas alors parcours de la
conviction que nous ne pourrons pas
accueillir massivement des gens qui ne
s'intègrent pas aujourd'hui parce qu'ils
vont c'est trop brutales et trop rapide
et c'est culturellement les frontières
sans trop s'en sont trop haut trop trop
zélé trop brutale c'est pour ça que je
suis persuadé qu'il faut qu'il faut
aujourd'hui travailler sur d'autres
plans est-ce que c'est pas une connerie
du patronat mondiale entre guillemets ce
que c'est pas l'idée d'avoir mondialisé
en se disant il n'y a que la
mondialisation qui fonctionne pour les
pour les produits pour les finances mais
pas pour les hommes mais
c'est un terreau question semble c'est
qu'à un moment donné c'est le monde
entier se dit mais finalement on l'a
voulu on l'a eu et on est en plein
dedans
on est en plein dedans on y va les
produits circulent pas de problème les
capitaux surtout non mais oui et les non
1060 and is seen on a fait des eaux
d'euros raffiné zone euro on a une même
mené c'est que je deviens des personnes
dont et les européens circulent très
bien très bien
les murs ne manque pas grand chose mais
on nie que vous avez il aurait mieux
procès que le micro qui va qui pose à
prendre parce qu'il ya plein de
subventions qui est plein jusqu'à vous
appliquerez à toi comme le nabot l'eau
qui a des besoins
c'est là où je viens comme problématique
c'est quand le type arrivent avec des
îles avec des nouveaux besoins
nous on a des chômeurs des gens des
employés à loger que j'ai chopé de
l'otan le logement un salarié qui gagne
le smic en région parisienne pour se
loger c'est compliqué je donc on a
beaucoup déjà sur l'eau un employé
français qui travaillent qui payent des
impôts qui paient les charges
il a du mal à se loger j'espère que la
priorité à moi en tant que patron était
lui trouver un logement
mais moi j'en suis malade ça déjà c'est
dommage que la pire tout ça quand je
sais les dommages collatéraux d'une
ambition mondiale c'est ça que je dis
mais je vous rejoins effectivement ces
gens là il va bien falloir encore cela
simplement l'intérêt d'absolution
il faut un logement et les applications
pour les gosses une fois une classe pour
12 et non pas une classe pour 25 des
frais et force le pays d'origine qui a
plus rien d'origine ya plus de détails
et quand il y en a il ya aussi souvent
de la corruption parce que politiquement
disons les choses oui ça arrange ça
arrange les grandes puissances bien
entendu d'avoir des dirigeants corrompus
du soja oui mais c'est vrai que nous
sommes audités et tous les tous les gens
qui connaissent le sujet de l'histoire
de la solution c'est en effet le
développement de ces pays ont poussé à
chaque fois mais un moment la vague
arrivera moi j'entends ça le
développement nord-sud le nord sud vers
la fin quand nord-sud comprend des prix
en jeu l'a jamais fait non mais non mais
où alors on l'a fait non c'est que ça
n'arrive pas mais le développement ne
reçut la coopération nord-sud la
coopération europe méditerranée moi
j'entends ça depuis que je suis môme
alors probablement que ça existe il ya
des vrais coopération sauf que c'est
capté et c'est pas ça existe tout n'est
pas capté ça existe et la france et
l'union européenne sont des mondes
parmi les puissances king qui aide le
plus cela étant on a peut-être essayé
d'autres choses
on a cassé des pays justement parce
qu'on avait le sentiment que c'était pas
redistributif simplement en cassant un
pays quand il ya plus d'états non plus
on peut me citer les pays que comme la
lybie moment donné il n'y a plus d'état
non plus donc en s'attaquant à ses
dirigeants pour dire vous déconnez il
faut redistribuer en six attaquants on
casse tout et quand on casse tout c'est
encore plus compliqué fric il y en a qui
n'a au canada mais qui bouge qui bouche
la chine
je m'estime beaucoup sans aucun état
d'âme
sauf que ce sont des étapes qu'on n'ira
pas fracasser non plus pour leur dire
vous êtes passé redistributif passé le
sas est le parrain ii tentera pas là il
ya six mois par et c'est le livre
d'ariane chemin et raphaëlle bacqué la
communauté dans laquelle quelques unes
des vedettes chapitre cité enfin c'est
ce que s'est dit va changer les choses à
bras parce que
pour des gars qu'on en parle toujours à
ce que ces deux doigts ça a été ça fait
beaucoup parler pour le coup ça fait
beaucoup parler mais bon ça a été ça a
été beaucoup médiatisé aussi à trappes
en a beaucoup parlé parce que par
définition on parlait de la vie mais il
sera intéressant parle de vous mais
c'est toujours un moment donné ça va
c'est retombé depuis et ça n'a pas
changé la face de la ville et ce n'était
pas l'objectif non plus livré non
l'objectif du leem étaient des affaires
d'état
voilà de raconter l'histoire d'une
migration parce que finalement c'est un
peu ça l'histoire de l'histoire vraie
d'une banlieue française c'est ce cette
immigration qui a eu dans les années
60-70 raconté donc par les deux
journalistes et en même temps essayant
de faire que de 2,2 d'expliquer pourquoi
tant de gens comme de bronze omar sy ont
pu émerger donc cette attention ces
territoires
voilà donc il ya une explication donc
c'est très intéressant mais ça n'a pas
changé ni la phase de trappes et la face
du monde mais par contre c'était
intéressant qu'on s'y arrête
mais pour lancer le débat au delà des
murs de trappes est ce que cette zone
d'éducation prioritaire
les culés qu pv maintenant parce que moi
de me pareil depuis que je suis môme il
ya des solutions plan banlieues
aujourd'hui tu pv dont cartier politique
de la ville donc ce sont les quartiers
accompagné par l'état dans le cadre de
l'anru pour la construction dans le
cadre des subventions pour les
associations en particulier
oui des quartiers entiers sont en zone
franche par les pourparlers entreprises
également c'est pas forcément les
meilleures solutions non plus on a le
premier que la gendarmerie les nations
qui corrige pas cibler le système c'est
un
un truc à trois pieds il ya les
entreprises qui financent le système la
gendarmerie qui forment et les grâces
ionale de crise nationale qui causent la
vie décès de faire découvrir des jeunes
loups de banlieue qu'il ya autre chose à
faire le soir pour que des conneries et
qu'on peut aussi s'occuper de sécuriser
des réseaux c'est intéressant et de
générer des vocations pour que ces
jeunes là bas deviennent soit trouvée
boulot soit trouve un
quelque chose soit soir entre comme
sous-officier de gendarmerie
donc la première la première promotion
est à trappes donc devant le medef va
même jusqu en sorte de douce la salle
chauffée de réserve de gendarmerie donc
mais celle de l'initiative c'est une
belle initiative qui permet sinon rien
de plus de plus le livre mais par contre
ça continue à bosser dans cette commune
c'est à dire que les associations sont
présents des associations font un boulot
exceptionnel ce dont on cite ce dont
vous parlez monsieur ce sont souvent les
exceptions et ses exceptions à son hyper
bruyante c'est vrai que c'est également
paroxystique tard pendant longtemps ça
se passe super bien et puis il ya des
événements des fois qu'ils font que ça
explose on a eu des événements la nuit
dernière dans d'autres communes un gamin
qui s'est fait tirer dessus
non c'était un homme bon et on voit bien
comment ça peut exploser
mais voilà mais à trappes c'est encore
une fois un paroxystique c'est à des
moments simplement où ça peut exploser
mais sinon ça buzz ça buzz ça bosse et
il y aurait beaucoup d'exemples à mettre
en valeur sa fille à mettre entre
l'ordre des prix justement est un
vecteur et je suis persuadé que le rôle
citoyen l'entreprise doit être renforcée
mais on n'en vient pas de modification
de la constitution le traînant sur le
rôle de l'entreprise dans le compliqué
alors autant je suis autant dans les 40
m de la loi d'état elle lâche que vous
avez dit est très distante mais là non
mais ça n'aurait pas être d'accord parce
que vous remettez contrainte
par contre il faut soit spontané mais
quand je vous parlerai que la france
était un pays de pme tpe pme qui sont
ancrés en territoire
donc en fait quand il faut autour d'eux
du bien et ça se ressent surtout
directement sur le nokia c2 leur terrain
de jeu donc et c'est très important pour
moi le roller c'est si les cadeaux faits
aux patrons mais les piétons font des
cadeaux la société enfin bref à tous et
faire des cadeaux c'est sympathique
d'éducation vous avez vu que des
professeurs vont être au pouvoir yeni
plus s'ils vont dans ces zones
c'est déjà le cas compliqué quand je
crois que se dénoncer
et alors si c'est si l'on crée alors on
peut se décider et on parle d'évaluation
des enseignants c'est quelque chose qui
vous choquent ou d'abord à évaluer
je suis évalué par les étudiants encore
montcourt est évalué par l'argent oui
mais jusque de ce crime et non mais on
pourrait le sait pas encore très clair
mais on pourrait soumettre
l'augmentation des revenus à
l'évaluation dont il ferait l'objet mais
fondamentalement c'est pas loin d'être
le cas en fin de ce que je connais de
l'enseignement secondaire
je sais qu'il ya des des enseignants qui
demandent à être évacués parce qu'ils ne
le sont pas suffisamment à londres être
inspectés pour pouvoir franchir des
classes et des échelons de carrière donc
ça revient au fond à ce que est ce que
vous dites alors dire il ya là pour le
coup des syndicats d'enseignants chez
pas lesquels qui sont très rétifs à ce
qu'on appelle la rémunération
l'évaluation ou mérite ce prêt le mérite
c'est pas un gros bien au contraire
j'y vois aucun inconvénient et notamment
leur valut d'ailleurs il faut savoir
qu'ils évaluent et et comment et comment
on construit le mérite pour un pour un
enseignant est ce que comme en mesure
mais c'est appeler valeur de
l'évaluation des ministres par leur
haine plus incommodés
1.8 c'est un peu le tir soit laissée là
il ya beaucoup d'évaluation partout y
compris à l'université jeu et là je vous
en parle des deux côtés j'ai été
évaluateurs des centres de recherche
pendant pendant ce temps là je nous
allons être évalués dans 6 mois
on passe notre temps à être évalué
peut-être un peu trop d'ailleurs
pendant ce temps pendant qu'on est
évaluée et qu'on se prépare à
l'émulation réalité on ne fait pas et on
se cale dans une optique qui n'est pas
celle de la de l'action mais
l'évaluation c'est toujours un beau
parce qu'il faut qu'on se quitte mais je
veux demander à paris hulot il reste ou
pas au gouvernement france je pense
qu'il reste
il reste parce qu'il fait pas grand
chose valentine mustapha bon il reste
bien évidemment non pas deux pour moi
c'est la continuité donc il va rester
que les dieux mais à moi parce que j'ai
lu il reste il reste fort si jamais des
vignobles vous recontacter on va vous
évaluez merci infiniment vers tours de
créer pour que ce rappel le voilà vous
êtes un des soutiens de geoffroy roux de
bézieux qui a été élu président du medef
merci beaucoup mustapha ben oui merci
beaucoup stéphane morceaux et florence
père cadets choqué et à bientôt recours
à nouveau parce que ce sera sans doute à
la rentrée prochaine
[Musique]